si l'on parle le fromage on doit d'abord
parler de cette dette
bosch 100000 chèvres dans la région ça
fait du bruit et surtout du les 64
millions de litres par an à partir de là
on fait surtout du fromage d'ailleurs
cinq son appellation d'origine protégée
pour les reconnaître c'est un peu comme
un cours de géométrie
le som maure de touraine un cylindre
avec une paille de dans le gris ni saint
pierre avec sa pyramide le crottin de
chavignol le selles sur cher et le
valence et enfin vous avez compris le
concept quoi justement le valence et
maintenant on passe aux cours d'histoire
selon la légende talleyrand c'est lui
reçoit napoléon au château de valençay
napoléon n'avait pas vraiment moral il
venait de perdre sa compagne en egypte
du coup talleyrand a fait décapiter les
fromages de valence et qui ressemblaient
trop aux pyramides
enfin on va pas en faire tout un fromage